hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Katie
du Bois we're gonna review the trailer
today for a hot pursuit
starring Reese Witherspoon and Sofia
Vergara I have been saying for years we
need a movie with Sophia Vergara and
Reese Witherspoon I always saw the combo
Oh like I wouldn't have thought that I
did good for you you know mm-hmm you
knew before the rest of us yeah I know
things good crossing yes he's the top
lieutenant in the cartel
he is known as the biker Bogota the
tender tender the lender Leonard Cortez
kills every witness
you're lucky that I'm at best chance you
have at surviving
what the hell is that white stuff
forward so I am
you're pretty else but our total at 4
feet 11 inches
Hong Kong the other suspect a 45 year
old Latino
I'm a little worried but Oh a little
appeal same time yeah I think that would
be fun I'm not sure I would see it in
the theater but I would totally watch it
with a couple bottles of wine yeah and
my friends were like a lot of cocaine
bringing you to the film and fun to use
yeah oh dude it's immersive when the
trailer was first starting out I was
like okay this looks like your standard
Hollywood comment yeah you know they're
really following the structure two very
opposite people and she's like the
really good cop but no one takes her
seriously yeah you know like everything
in the way it was playing out taking
away Miss Congeniality it was it was
like a lot of other companies combined
into one willing to start off but then
as it progressed I started to join it
more and I think it's because I think
the two actresses chemistry as I saw it
developing in the trailer looked more
appealing than the script itself like
the script looks kind of whatever but
their interaction looks like they're
really had fun on set yeah well an
sophie is just so animated if you don't
get that all that's
I'm from comedies with me major females
I mean when she was like screaming out
of the car I mean that to me was super
fun like that was something hadn't seen
before and she is like [ __ ] beautiful
I know totally outshine the other spoon
will Reese Witherspoon's have like a
scrunchie in her hair and like old lady
panties on
I just think Reese Witherspoon even on
our best days does not look as good as
Sofia Vergara I just wanna just want to
point that out she's gorgeous
I mean something gonna be like nah yes
no it's no big tits
yeah Sofia Vergara she's a really great
like she's beautiful but she's also a
really good community actress yeah and
Reese Witherspoon she's really good with
comedy too she's done a comedy in a
while yeah but that's definitely like
the faith like the basis the foundation
of her career has been comedy yeah when
she really broke out it was Legally
Blonde oh yeah you know like I know she
had other films before that but it was
legally wanna really like Center which
is great at drama too so I think her
skills as an actor have really improved
from doing a lot of dramatic work
definitely that now putting her into a
colony like this for she's League last
night I think she did was This Means War
which was not a very good comedy but
this one you know she's the actual star
of it so I feel like taking that level
of commitment to a role and putting it
in there and I feel like they allowed
her to improvise too yeah you know that
you could tell by the interaction that
they were probably like I don't think
we've ever gotten a chance to really see
her improv skills and she rocked that
Spanish she did she I was I was
impressed that was like that was good I
don't speak Spanish but I could tell
that was good Spanish yeah that'll be
fun for a lot of audiences extra yeah I
like how they just didn't make it like
how you're Hispanic and you're white
like I like I was actually beyond that
like I don't think I even heard a joke
like that
no except when she didn't call her like
she said in Spanish
well maybe underwear maybe yeah I like
that like they don't get along at first
but then they're gonna have to get along
and work together and they
yeah like best of friends but I could
have used more though from the trailer
actually I feel like the trailer could
have been maybe a little bit longer and
giving me just like a little bit more
yeah I got excited about I feel like
what they showed him like the last half
of the trailer that the heart of it is
what I thought was is that first I
thought like oh they're trying to be
really funny right now yeah but it
wasn't so they started showing some
heart between the characters what are
you saying I'm not man saying like
you're a big teddy bear
you see I'm not fat I'm saying that
you're like a big trim teddy bear it
looks like a great comedy I can't wait I
mean I can't wait to see it but
hopefully when it comes out the reviews
are good you got the heat and you got
[ __ ] bridesmaids and then you got
identity theft and dynamic duo's dynamic
duo's rush hour you know you take two
complete opposites and you put them
together and hilarity ensues it's a
couple The Odd Couple anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects katie has
a channel to a lot of comedy on there
check that shiznit out Ryan it's ng hi
I'm from SE Asia Malaysia a Joe Malaysia
over here I always see their videos on
YouTube is very awesome trailer reaction
and discussion
well anyway keep making more awesome
video to us Ryan Ning knew the Asian
Malaysian is the way to go man oh she's
just a baby
oh man you want cool young looking Asian
kid
yeah I guess that's a thought but you're
just like a guy with glasses looking at
a photo selfie
first off everyone knows what the good
selfie what you gotta do is you gotta
take it from an upward angle like that
uh-huh because it makes you look thinner
slimmer and you get more in the shot
this down point of view you got to stop
doing that man if you want a good selfie
you guys talk doing you look really
depressed you're not gonna get [ __ ]
that way my friend all right look
is that weird to say to a kid yes stay
in the video